lulao bolsonaro en la primera semana
tras la primera vuelta electoral
importantes respuestas el líder de
izquierda Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva
recibió el apoyo del partido democrático
laborista cuarto en las elecciones con
3,5 millones de votos pese a estar
ubicado en la centro izquierda el
candidato siro Gómez ha sido uno de los
máximos enemigos de Lula Aunque antes de
romper relaciones fue suministro por su
parte el presidente Jair bolsonarok ya
ha recibido el apoyo de los gobernadores
de los tres estados más poblados de
Brasil Rodrigo García de Sao Paulo
Romeo sema de minas gerais y Claudio
Castro de Río de Janeiro en sus colegios
electorales votan 63 millones de
electores de los 156 que tiene el país
además de estos rápidos movimientos
todavía hay expectativa por saber a
quién brindará apoyos y montebet tercera
más votada con cerca de 5 millones de
votos y ubicada en la centro de derecha
pero fue una de las impulsoras de la
investigación contra bolsonaro en el
parlamento por su gestión de la pandemia
mientras se dan los movimientos
políticos los candidatos buscan los
votos religiosos bolsonaro en una
iglesia evangélica
doy gracias a Dios por mi familia mi
segunda oportunidad en la vida en mi
misión y con las personas a mi lado
[Música]
Lula por su parte se acercó a la iglesia
católica
el Papa Francisco ha sido un hombre de
valor ejemplar
en primera vuelta Lula consiguió el
48,4% de los votos contra el 43,2% de
bolsonaro el nuevo presidente saldrá de
la votación en segunda vuelta del 30 de
octubre